le 24 décembre 1865 un certain nombre de
jeunes gens étaient réunis chez un juge
dans une petite localité de l'état
américain du tennessee qui s'appelait
pulawski pulawski ça n'est pas une cité
dont on connaît le nom ça n'est pas un
lieu historique et probablement nous
n'aurions jamais eu l'occasion de parler
de pôle afs qui si justement ces jeunes
gens n'avaient pas été réunies là ce
soir d'ailleurs pulaski pour votre
information
c'est le nom d'un noble polonais épris
de liberté qui était venu mettre son
épée au service du général washington
pendant la guerre d'indépendance et qui
est mort justement pendant cette guerre
on a donné son nom à cette petite
localité
ces jeunes gens qui étaient là réunis la
veille de noël étaient tous d'anciens
combattants de la guerre de sécession
cette guerre qui s'était acheté
seulement quelques mois au havre il faut
bien dire que ces jeunes gens s'ennuient
brive ou dans une guérite m'est arrivé
beaucoup de choses on peut être tuer ça
alors c'est fini évidemment peut-être
blessé on peut être prisonnier on peut
aussi survivre tels que le bon dieu vous
a fait c'était le cas de ces jeunes gens
qui étaient ademe et qu'ils s'ennuyaient
parce que mon dieu sortir d'une guerre
et retrouver la paix c'est quelquefois
ennuyeux alors qu'ils étaient là ils se
sont dit mais si on faisait un club si
on se réunissait
l'idée était bonne
et aussitôt elle a été voté par
acclamation quand la diva d'accord on va
faire un club on va essayer de récolter
des adhérents autant que possible des
gens comme nous qui ont qui avons fait
la guerre mais il faut un nom un club à
ça c'est la difficulté si vous avez fait
ce genre d'opération c'est arrivé à
beaucoup de gens ben vous savez on bute
là quand on cherche un an
piana un de ces jeunes gens qui étaient
plus instruits que les autres et qui
avait fait du grec autrefois l'école dit
nous sommes un anneau nous voulons faire
un cercle d'amis et bien cercle en grec
ça se dit kuklos à coke l'eau c'est très
bien ma façon un peu compliquée et
l'autre dimension s'amuser si on mettait
un x1 nu ça ferait cucq luxe pas mal
mais c'est trop court que klux klux club
arsenal est pas c'était pas phonétique
et là ils se sont souvenus qu'ils
étaient tous il était si cela se sont
souvenus qu'ils étaient tous d'origine
écossaise lointainement écossaise alors
il ya des clans en écosse plus klux klan
avec un c banon puisqu'on a déjà mis un
cas à cucq l'os du rac luxe avec un cas
on va mettre un cas à klan voilà comment
est né le ku klux klan voilà donc le
début de cette étrange affaire de cette
étrange histoire et quelques jours plus
tard nous sommes en janvier 1866 on se
réunit de nouveau ça y est le ku klux
klan existe qu'est ce qu'on va lui
trouver comme originalité est quelqu'un
dont l'histoire n'a pas retenu le nom
quelqu'un divers relations se déguiser
toujours très amusant de se déguiser
pourquoi pas aiguisé on peut faire des
farces des peut-être plaisanterie sous
un déguisement sous un masque et on
imagine de revêtir une des grandes robes
et aussi une cagoule une cagoule pointu
avec deux trous pour
les yeux un trouble pour la bouche et
les premiers membres du ku klux klan
sont sortis ainsi accoutré dans les rues
de poulet ce qu'il faut croire que ça
intéresser les gens puisqu'un certain
nombre de d'habitants de la ville ont
cherché à adhérer au club on l'a reçu
leur adhésion au bout de quelques
semaines ils étaient 400 cette même
énorme 400 dans une petite ville et les
400 décidé alors de montrer ce qu'ils
étaient à tout le reste de
l'agglomération
400 qui avaient tous fait faire chez eux
par leurs femmes leurs fiancés ou leur
fille l'accoutrement qui était de
rigueur dans les statuts la grande
europe et la cagoule
les deux trous les trois trous et 400
muni d'un cheval qui se sont retrouvés à
l'heure dite au rendez vous
c'était la nuit une nuit sans lune et
ils s'étaient séparés par plusieurs
groupes et à l'heure dite
or qui avaient été fixés ce sont
d'anciens militaires il pénètre dans la
ville par des avenues par des rues
différentes à cheval les chevaux eux
mêmes sans caparaçonnés de blanc jusqu'à
le jusqu'à terre jusqu'aux pieds la tête
du cheval aussi
et imaginez la pression sur les
habitants de poule f qui ne se doute de
rien car on a gardé le secret imaginez
l'impression de cette troupe de
cavaliers fantômes qui apparaît dans la
nuit et ses colonnes de cavaliers
suivent un itinéraire il traverse la
ville de part en part les autres
arrivent par là ils se recroisent ils
reviennent et finalement ça donne
l'impression d'une foule immense et on
dira le lendemain matin pour la wsk ils
étaient au moins 3000 et n'étaient que
400 mais il avait fait de l'effet comme
s'il avait été trois mais non alors
jusque là il n'ya pas particulièrement
d'originalité sauf peut être cet
accoutrement
mais tout à coup
les membres du ku klux klan s'aperçoit
que naturellement ils ont fait trembler
les vieilles dames les enfants les vieux
messieurs blancs de la ville mais qu'il
y a des gens qui ont eu une frousse du
diable et que ces gens là ce sont les
noirs
il ya beaucoup de moi sommes dans le sud
ce sont les noirs qui viennent d'être
émancipé émancipé par la guerre par la
victoire du nord et quand il s'aperçoit
qu'ils font peur comme on dit comme ils
disent on est gros tout à coup la
véritable orientation du ku klux klan va
se découvrir d'elle-même alors pourquoi
mais pourquoi c'est toute la question
doit c'est toute la question noire vous
savez que le grand problème c'est l
esclavage vous savez que dans le sud
dans toutes les contrées du sud des
états unis en cultive le coton on l'a
dit c'est le roi coton alors pour
cultiver le coton il faut d'immenses
quantités de main d'oeuvre
il y a trois millions cinq cent mille
esclaves dans le sud des états unis
esclaves noirs bien sûr descendant
d'africain immigrés de force les
négriers vous connaissez toute cette
histoire
et au moment de la révolution moment de
la dépendance on avait posé la question
de l' esclavage dans la résoudre à ce
moment là la population du nord et la
population du sud s'équilibre et
washington ne voulait pas de conflit
alors on avait laissé la question pour
plus tard mais voilà c'est que la
démographie la démographie quelque chose
qui quelquefois porte en elle même ses
leçons
alors que la fin du xviiie siècle les
deux populations le nord et le sud s'est
équilibré en 1860 sur 33 millions
d'habitants
il ya 20 millions de gens dans le nord
et le reste est dans le sud y compris
trois millions et demi d'esclaves noirs
il ya donc déséquilibré dans le nord de
moins en moins on supporte qu'il y ait
de l' esclavage dans le sud car on
trouve cela immoral injustifiable
philosophiquement ni religieusement
nîmes de quelque façon que ce soit
d'ailleurs injustifiable et il y à des
groupes très actifs dans le nord qui
demande la suppression d' esclavage le
suit bien entendu se cramponne dit nous
voulons garder cet esclavage ou gardons
jusqu'au bout sans esclaves que serions
nous le coton et pili à des ligues dans
le nord qui facilite l'évasion des
esclaves biya en disant cent mille
esclaves que l'on aide à s'évader vers
le nord c'est ce qu'on appelle
lunderground railway et puis il ya ce
roman que vous connaissez tous la case
de l'oncle tom qui paraît en 1850 madame
pêcheurs sto et qui fait pleurer des
millions d'yeux aux états unis et dans
le monde entier d'ailleurs qui raconte
les malheurs des esclaves et c'est vrai
et c'est vrai que cette situation et est
affreuse
il faut pas évidemment tout noircir et
certains historiens ont dit que on avait
tendance à user d'un certain manichéisme
il fallait pas voir la situation des
esclaves entièrement j'allais dire
entièrement noir non pardon entièrement
sombre dans le sud des états unis
il est certain qu'il y avait des
familles des plantations les esclaves
étaient heureux mais qu'il advienne que
dans ces familles le maître moeurs ou
qu'il fasse de mauvais à faire alors on
vendait les esclaves et c'était ce
marché ces marchés d'esclaves auquel
nous ne pouvons pas penser sans sans me
sentir mal à l'aise ces familles que
l'on séparés brutalement se marient
séparé de sa femme cette mère séparée de
ses enfants ses scènes absolument des
chiens et rui tout cela ait existé et ça
on ne peut pas le rayer l'histoire alors
le sud essayé de se défendre le sud se
défend lui le moins en moins et en 1860
abraham lincoln avait été élu président
des états unis avec
comme programme l'abolition des
esclavages aussitôt après les états du
sud se réunissaient en confédération et
c'était la guerre cette guerre a été
terrible une guerre qui a causé un
nombre de pertes considérables dans des
conditions abominables
une led guère d'ailleurs les guerres
sont toujours l'aide mais celle là en
particulier une guerre héroïque aussi
bien sûr mais enfin c'est le sud qui a
perdu alors juste avant la guerre un
voyageur avait interrogé un esclave un
vieil esclaves un cocher qu'on lui avait
affecté et il y avait 10 mai enfin
est-ce que parmi vous les esclaves on
parle quelquefois de liberté c'est
esclaves avaient répondu monsieur on ne
parle que de liberté
alors si avant la guerre les esclaves
penser cela imaginez leur état d'esprit
pendant la guerre latente les champs qui
s'élève dans leurs cases dans les
plantations dans les champs chant
d'espoir et puis tout à coup la victoire
du nord est puis l'arrivée dans les
plantations dans les maisons des
esclaves dans les cases par tous des
soldats du nord qui cris liberté liberté
vous êtes libre et puis les scènes
d'émotion qui nous ont été dépeinte par
les noirs eux mêmes dans des récits
touchant les noirs qui quitte la
plantation le plus souvent il faut bien
le dire est qu'ils s'en vont à l'avant
turquie s'en vont vers les villes qui
s'en vont ailleurs ils veulent aller
ailleurs pour la première fois de leur
vie ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent
et puis enfin il y en a un qui a écrit
cela c'est très joli il y en a un qui
dit est dit et puis nous avions
l'habitude de penser qu'un homme libre
était un homme riche va bien sur wii
lors leur mettre leurs propriétaires
étaient riches et ils étaient libres
alors nous qui devions qui devenu en
quelque sorte libre nous pensons qu'une
allons être automatiquement riche il a
fallu seulement quelques semaines pour
savoir que si la liberté donné la fierté
elle ne l'est pas la richesse alors
surtout il y a dans ce sud matin une
occupation une occupation militaire très
rude
cette occupation se double d'un certain
nombre de mesures bien sûr la liberté
totale pour les esclaves mais aussi de
mesures politiques par exemple on va
décréter que les gens du sud qui avait
prêté serment aux états unis et qui
depuis le resserrement avaient conspiré
ou pris les armes contre les états unis
cela ne pourrait plus voter
disons que c'était le cas de la plupart
des gens du sud
éminent en revanche en 1866 sont donné
le droit de vote ou noir et on assiste
est évidemment à ce que les gens du sud
trouvé intolérable c'est que nouveauté
pâques mais que l'or noir leur noir
comment nos noir vous pensez donc que
voter et puis il y avait derrière les
armes et des gens alors la moins
défendables des gens qu'on appelait le
carpe et bikers parce qu'ils arrivaient
avec un petit sac en tapisserie et puis
c'est carpet bagger sérieux pour faire
des affaires alors là ils s'allier avec
des noirs leurs frais à manger à boire
et puis peu à peu conquérir des marchés
conquérait pouvez acheter des
plantations à l'abandon et on les a
hissés et il y avait aussi des braves
gens des très proches jean des gens bien
qui étaient des instituteurs qui
arrivait aussi et eux simplement voulez
apprendre à lire et à écrire au noir
mais ces gens là on les a hissés aussi
il y avait dans ce sud
un climat qui montaient qui allait de
plus en plus loin qui atteignait une
sorte de paroxysme de colère et de haine
la haine c'est terrible à m c'est
peut-être je crois de de tous les
sentiments dont l'homme est capable vous
savez qu'il est capable de beaucoup de
choses
la haine c'est ce qu'il y a pire
et ces gens haïssent et
alors imaginez cette petite localité de
poule f ce qu'ils puissent eux gens qui
s'amusent se déguisent et qu'ils
aperçoivent qui font peur aux noirs à
ces salons de negro ils ont la frousse
on avait donc un moyen de pression sur
eux eh bien on allait vite s'en servir
lors début ça n'a pas dépassé le stade
de la plaisanterie ont repéré un noir
par exemple qui dont on savait qu'il
fréquentait beaucoup les radicaux les
radicaux c'était le parti politique à
l'époque le parti politique du nord est
lors les radicaux s'implanter dans le
sud est évidemment faisait de la
propagande auprès des noix l'ont repéré
un noir qui fréquentaient les radicaux
dont on pensait même qui l'avait voté
radical alors on allait chez lui et
évidemment ont joué le jeu jusqu'au bout
s'il avait peur les noirs c'est parce
que c'était des créatures qui ne
connaissaient pas ces gens vêtus de ces
cagoules mais est-ce que ça n'était pas
des fantômes et oui ce sont des fantômes
et on arrivait en dix ans d'une voix
caverneuse
j'ai soif negro de noix bois ont levé
gros apporter une tasse avec de l'eau
non à bach et un grand bac l'autre
apporté à mac et est évidemment le cloud
ce mannequin on les appelait déjà les
classes man legends du ku klux klan
avait sous sa cagoule à grand shaq et
dans ce grand sac ils engloutissent et
le bac et bac voyons alors le noir était
dans tous ses états il expliqué tout à
sa famille à ses amis et un fantôme hier
soir il a bu pour the matter ou une
autre fois on s'approchait d'un noir la
nuit tout ça se passait la nuit et on
lui disait donne moi la main negro lors
le negro tout en tremblant donner la
main et on lui tendait dans la manche
delà de la grande robe une main de
squelette
alors l'autre touché la main du
squelette voilà tout ça on thione
ne pas vendable mais on est allé tout de
suite beaucoup plu tout de suite parce
que il y a eu un éclatement du ku klux
klan c'était comme si cela correspondait
à une sorte de deux mouvements spontanés
irrationnelle et oui l'éclatement c'est
ça c'est l'éclatement et déjà il y a un
cul klux klan dans la ville d'à côté
at-elle ce et puis dans le village d'à
côté et puis encore plus loin et bientôt
il ya tant de clans dans toute la région
qu'il faut faire un congrès et nous
sommes aux débuts de 1867 et ces gens
vont définir leur doctrine cette
doctrine c'est quelque chose il qui dans
leur esprit est analogue à une
chevalerie étanche chevalerie mais pour
eux le clan c'est la pureté
d'abord la pureté de la race la leur car
ces gens et ça ne faut pas perdre de vue
cette idée là ces gens au départ sont
des américains qui se veulent des
américains de pure souche
ils sont protestants et veulent
seulement descendre des fondateurs qui
eux étaient protestants vous avez un
bateau lemay flower qui est arrivé un
beau jour il y avait que des puritains
alors dans l'idée dé des vrais ceux qui
se disent les vrais américains par
exemple les catholiques qui sont venus
plus tard les irlandais les italiens
catholiques bien ce sont des intrus
alors la religion catholique est à
proscrire
alors le clan se veut un groupement de
vrais américains les purs amérique
et puis d'américains qui suivent le vrai
et christianisme à l'exclusion des
catholiques on veut on prête serment qu
on est contre le catholicisme et bien
sûr on est également contre les [ __ ]
voilà c'est ça c'est simple mais alors
justement comment se veut une sorte de
chevalerie et bien on à l'uniforme de
cette chevalerie et puis on imagine des
titres lors le grand chef du clan de ce
qu'on va appeler l'invisible empire
le grand chef du clan c'est le grand
sorcier en dessous pour gouverner les
états c'est-à-dire les royaumes dans
leur jargon et bien ce sont les grands
dragons en dessous les circonscriptions
plus étroite les grands titans et puis
les petites circonscriptions les grands
cyclope sauce aurait tendance à rire
mais ne riez pas héricy peuple qu'ils
ont voulu se désigner un grand sorcier
digne de leur organisation ils avaient
déjà plusieurs dizaines de milliers le
mans et sont allés voir le général lee
le héros de l'armée sudiste le grand
soldat qui a dû non non ça ne
m'intéresse pas mais il aurait dit si
vous voyez le général fort est peut-être
acceptera-t-il sont allés voir le
général forrest qui les a écoutés qui
est du jeu connaît votre cul fixe clan
c'est quelque chose de très bien
j'accepte faut dire que le général
forest pendant la guerre alors qu'un
régime en noir se rendaient avait
ordonné massacrer tous les [ __ ] et on
avait massacré tous les negro il n'y
avait donc pas dans l'esprit du général
forest de sensiblerie déplacés d'autant
plus s'il faut le dire aussi que avant
la guerre il était lui même un très
grand marchand d'esclaves à main pis il
avait fait fortune dans le commerce des
esclaves peut pas dire que il était
partisan du nouveau système l'ancien
préfet rey et le général forest est
devenu le premier grand sorcier impérial
et tout de suite on est passé à l'action
contre les noirs contre les noirs
rallier contre les noirs sympathisants
radicalisme et puis aussi contre ceux
des noirs qui par leur travail
depuis qu'ils étaient libres un travail
souvent acharnées avait réussi à se
faire une modeste aisance et puis aussi
on est passé à l'action contre les
blancs que l'on reprochait d'être les
amis des noirs
alors première action et vous savez
c'est très difficile il y à des normes
étude sur le ku klux klan et qui
renferme des centaines et des centaines
d'histoires il faut choisir
il ya en france et en particulier un
livre tout à fait remarquable de denis
baldès berger qui cite comme ses
confrères américains des centaines de
cas est bien choisi sion alors
arbitrairement lewis
citons un nom lewis et le noir lewis
lewis faire connaissance de blanc il a
été aux réunions politiques qu'il a été
séduit par la doctrine radical et une
vote radical on frappe à sa porte voix
caverneuse à l'extérieur c'est la nuit
ouvre nom du christ
lewis et la pauvre femme de lewis qui
dit tu entendu te demande d'ouvrir
je n'ouvrirai pas d'idées aux is au nom
du christ ouvre où tu vas mourir lewis
alors la lewis pouf se trouve en joue
tenu en joue les a là des hommes vêtus
de cagoules
on l'emmène au fond d'une forêt on lui
dénude le torse est long le bas à coups
de fouet vous savez c'est énorme fou et
qui servent pour les animaux et qui d'un
seul coup
enlève un morceau de chair alors le bas
hurle de douleur il dit mais monsieur
mais messieurs
qu'est ce que j'ai fait vous me
connaissez je suis le pauvre [ __ ] lewis
je n'ai rien fait de mal messieurs et on
lui dit est-ce que tu ne vas pas avec
des radicaux lewis j'ai des bons amis
blancs messieurs ils sont radicaux lewis
peut-être messieurs mais je n'ai pas
fait de mal est-ce que tu n'aurais pas
par hasard mis un bulletin de vote
radical messieurs j'ai écouté mes amis
blancs ils m'ont conseillé de voter j'ai
voté comme ils me l'ont dit nous n'avons
pas d'instructions nous autres les nerfs
et on arrêtera de le battre que quand il
leur a promis de ne pas voter radicale
aux prochaines élections mais démocrates
c'est à dire à cette époque partie du
site
alors ça c'est un camus il est anodin
parce que il ya le cas d'autres fans je
vous parlais de ces noirs par exemple la
famille de périgée farce c'est un noir
qui travaillait sur une prétendue une
plantation et qui au moment de la de
l'affranchissement de la libération
général a obtenu de son maître d'être
métayer d'une certaine surface et comme
il a des fils qui sont des gaillards
dont on travaille dur et mon dieu il a
acquis en deux ans une certaine aisance
alors vous pensez bien que pour les
blancs c'est une insulte épouvantable
comment un negro qui s'enrichit et on
veut le punir alors on décide une
expédition et qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
aime bien périgée faire ce qu'ils
viennent l'avertir qu'il dit mais fit
web péri le culte luxe l'on va débarquer
chez toi alors on monte la garde toutes
les nuits chez périgée faire s'il ya le
père et les fils qui sont armés qui
montent la garde aux limites de la
propriété et en soit voilà le ku klux
klan et périgée faire ce qu'il discerne
les ombres dans la nuit qui dit arrêtez
vous messieurs vous êtes sur ma
propriété vous n'avez pas le droit
d'entrée on va s'gêner cris les autres
en riant attention messieurs nous sommes
armés mais fils est moins avancé plus où
nous tairons et les autres de rire de
plus belle à un [ __ ] qui tire enfin
c'est pas sérieux et il avance et un
coup de feu dans la nuit et un blanc
temps on emmène le cadavre et à ce
moment-là périgée faire c'est qu'il ait
perdu définitivement perdue parce que le
ku klux klan ne le lâchera plus alors
dès le lendemain il s'enfuit avec ses
fils chez un shérif qui leur donnent
l'hospitalité et la nuit suivante
le propriétaire de la plantation entend
du bruit la dent sur le petit domaine
qu'il a attribué au périgée faire s'il y
court et voit dans la nuit des cagoules
qui s'en vont qui ont fini leurs besoins
gay dans la cour de la petite ferme il
ya un tas de meubles de chaises de
tables qui brûle
hélas une poutre il y a une forme qui se
balance c'est la mer que périgée verse
avait laissé ne pensais pas qu'on s'en
prendre à une femme femme seule il a
laissé cette femme d'autant plus qu'elle
avait un tout petit bébé
il voulait pas emmené le bébé alors la
femme elle est pendu quant au bébé dans
son berceau mais le berceau et sur le
tas de meubles qui brûle on l'a fusillé
l'enfant et on le brûle et on l'a brûlée
ensuite alors le propriétaire haletant
de dépendre la malheureuse femme elle
vit encore léger faire ce qu'on leur
dise fuyez partait dans un autre état le
shérif lui-même lecture conseille de
partir ils partent secrètement monte
dans un train qui s'en va vers l'état
voisin
ils ont traversé tous les tailles
commencent à respirer c'est la dernière
station est là la dernière station tout
à coup des hommes masqués monte dans le
train vous connaissez vous avez vu ça
dans des westerns
mais là c'est vrai cette histoire là ils
montent ils font tous le train le
couloir central et tout à coup il tombe
sur périgée faire ses fils allait perry
dessins et les fils descendez aussi le
lendemain on retrouvera les cadavres de
périgée fait recette ses fils criblé de
balles un cas entre des centaines de cas
et puis il ya les blancs oui cornelius
mcbride un exemple un instituteur blanc
il apprend à lire et à écrire au noir
alors un soir on l'enlève
il est battu à mort dans un bois son dos
est entamée depuis les omoplates jusqu'à
la pliure des genoux on voit plus ce que
c'est si c'est de la peau de la chair du
sang arraché 175 coup et puis il supplie
car la souffrance est abominable tuez
moi un homme s'approche à caravelle
verra là où on va tuer et puis on dit
non il n'a pas le droit
revolver on va le pendre allons le
détache pour le temps et puis l'aperçoit
perçoit qu'il y à une palissade un peu
plus loin et puis un homme seul
entre la palestine ens de toutes les
forces qui lui restent renverse l'homme
sont la palissade c la nuit et s'évade
en courant on tire on tire on tire on ne
rattrapera pas et ce qui est plus
extraordinaire c'est que quand ni luxe
made by ne partira pas et continuera
enseigner les noirs je parlais de héros
n'y a pas que dans les guerres qui
l'envoie là l'action le ku klux klan ce
qui est terrible c'est qu'elle a une
répercussion fatalement il ya toujours à
la violence une autre violence et que
l'occupation du nord se fait de plus en
plus lourdes
autant l'emportent le vent pense que
vous êtes nombreux à avoir lu ce beau
roman margaret mitchell ou avoir vu le
film est bien quand on nous montre tous
ces gens qu'on jette en prison ces gens
qu'on empêche de travailler ces gens
vraiment qu il gémit sous une très rude
occupation c'est vrai aussi mais ce
serait beaucoup moins rude s'il n'y
avait pas les excès du ku klux klan
alors c'est peut-être pour cela que a
beau jour en 69
le général forest décide de mettre fin
au club ce camp et il fait d'une
proclamation disant ah ben oui c'est
fini nous n'avons plus de raison d'être
d'ailleurs nous avons réussi l'ordre
règne
et puis il y avait des noirs autrefois
qui violé nos femmes et nos fils et
neige on leur donnait 10 dollars
d'amendé
nous avons mis fin à ses excès bien sûr
le culte sans rentrer dans les prisons
il prend les [ __ ] sont les juges et ça
c'est une solution alors nous avons
réussi messieurs rentrons chez nous
détruisons les insignes et c'est ce qui
est fait c'est ce qui est fait sauf tout
de même une clandestinité qui va se
poursuivre parce que l'occupation cesse
et les blancs du sud sont décidés à
aller jusqu'au bout dans la reconquête
de leurs privilèges qui ne volent pas
rétablir l'esclavagé
bien sûr mais ils ne veulent plus qu'il
y ait égalité entre les blancs et les
noirs
alors il y aura une série d'actes dans
tous les états du sud qui construiront
ce système qui a duré si longtemps et
qui dure encore en partie et qui
s'appelle la ségrégation raciale
alors il ya matin des établissements
pour les blancs des établissements pour
les noirs des moyens de transport pour
les blancs des moyens de transport pour
les noirs des cafés des écoles ah oui
l'école pour les noirs écoles pour les
blancs et alors ceux des noirs qui
voudraient tout de même voter encore
parce que c'est dans la loi normalement
ils pourraient voter ont fait des actes
qui les empêche de voter et ne voteront
plus pendant un siècle et ceux qui se
rebellent avions les accuse de tel et
tel délit et puis il ya une loi qui est
exercé une loi qui est non écrite et
cette loi c'est le lâche alors malheur
aux [ __ ] qui sont victimes du linge
ils n'iront pas très loin pas même
jusqu'au bout de la rue voilà voilà la
ségrégation raciale et on pourrait finir
là l'histoire du ku klux klan kkk c'est
déjà une histoire une histoire mais
c'est une histoire à rebondissements
car en 1905
on publie aux états unis un roman il
faut croire à la puissance des romans
dans l'histoire des moeurs parce que si
la case de l'oncle tom a joué un rôle
celui dont je vous parlais en a joué à
l'autre dans l'autre sens
car ce roman s'appelle de klinsmann et
on dit que c'est une histoire romancée
du cube luxe
et ce roman est lu par tous c'est une
nation admirable c'est l'histoire d'un
colonel sudiste qui s'appelle ben
cameron et qui est libéré après la fin
de la guerre naturellement rentrer dans
le club luxe clan devient grand dragon
pourquoi pas et la fée fait des choses
admirables parce que bien entendu dans
ce roman le public ce clan quelque chose
d'admirable et le bnd cameron est un
héros infiniment sympathique
il n'y a que les negro qui sont
antipathiques puis les carpettes bagasse
qui sont antipathiques et ben cameron
est tout de même poursuivi par les
forces du nord
il est avec sa femme qu'il adore et puis
cette femme est obligée pour échapper à
ses poursuivants de se jeter du haut
d'une colline et ça n'est qu'un peu plus
tard que ben cameron trouve le cadavre
de sa femme elle est morte mais unique
elle a les yeux grands ouverts et
imprégné sur ses yeux il y a les visages
de ceux qui l'ont mise à mort c'est
admirable faut soumettre sa l'académie
des sciences mais enfin ben cameron ne
songe pas à l'académie des sciences et
poursuit les autres puis ça finira très
bien par la vengeance mais alors ce
roman est lu comme on imagine pas qu en
remet en piste plus surtout dans le sud
car enfin tous ces gens-là revivre leur
histoire enfin elle est en obligeant
plus leur histoire et puis il ya
quelqu'un qui fera un film avec ce roman
c'est griffiths et ce sera vous le savez
naissance d'une nation
le premier grand chef-d'oeuvre du cinéma
dommage d'ailleurs que le premier grand
chef-d'oeuvre du cinéma soit un film
raciste
il ya en 1915 quand on projettera
atlanta ce film quelqu'un qui regardera
ce film c'est un certain simone simons
que a grandi avec sa mamie noir qui lui
parlait du clan autrefois l'ours est une
somme une sorte de légende dans son
esprit
et puis simons qui s'est engagé à 16 ans
dans l'armée qui a fait la guerre contre
l'espagne qui a appris le patriotisme le
drapeau le nationalisme et puis enfin
qui a été pasteur mais pas longtemps
qu'ils étaient commerçants et puis et
tout à coup on voit ce film il est
enthousiasmé et en 1865 ce mois de
novembre il convoque 40 personnes dans
un hôtel de la ville
et ces personnes il les conduit sur une
coline ce qui s'appelle stone mountain
et là ils l'auraient ils dressent une
grande croix de pain résineux qui la
portent et l'après midi y met le feu ça
brûle et simons déclare l'invisible
empire et restaurer et bien entendu
c'est lui qui est un grand sorcier du
pile klux klan et ça va très vite parce
qu'ils sont très rapidement des
centaines
et puis des milliers ils sont des
centaines et des milliers m mais voici
d'ailleurs la maison la maison de simons
wassit simons qui a l'air d'un petit
bourgeois américain voilà déjà les
premiers adhérents
les premiers adhérents du club ce clan
nouvelles manières avec les cagoules
maintenant cette fois il ya des
cérémonies publiques
il y a la fameuse crois qu'on brûle
toujours
et il ya surtout cette extraordinaire
attrait du mystère qui sentent qu'ils
sont ces gens qui sont ces gens revêtu
de la robe blanche en général ce sont
des petits employés des artisans des
gens qui m'ont dieu socialement ne sont
pas grand-chose voyez vous je crois même
qu'il doit y avoir aussi beaucoup
d'hommes beaucoup de marie qui lie à la
maison se laisse entièrement mener par
le bout du nez ça existe ce sont des
gens qui à qui la vie n'offrent aucune
occasion d'évasion rien rien du tout et
ces gens là qui sont qui sont rien eh
bien tout à coup se trouve fort sous la
cagoule parce qu'ils sont nombreux ils
sont là qu'il y a des mots d'ordre alors
en 1917 le ku klux klan sert à maintenir
l'ordre mais tout ça n'est pas grand
chose encore une sans corps que quelques
milliers ça n'est qu'en 1920 tout à coup
que un agent publicité et une femme qui
s'appelle madame tyler qui est également
agent de publicité viens viens
rencontrer six mondes celui dit vous ne
savez pas il fait on va vous expliquer
et c'est ça c'est de la pure par lequel
klux klan
parce que des agents de publicité ça
c'est exactement ce qu'il faut faire
alors que jusque-là simons parle très
bien
m'enfin tout de même il est affable la
tribune et bien après l'intervention le
clark et de madame times
il arrive dans la salle on a convoqué
grande quantité de public
et là il pose d'abord il ouvre sa veste
il pose un colt sur le la tribune il
prend dans une poche un revolver et dans
une poche encore un poignard qu'il
frappe au milieu des deux armes et il
dit et maintenant qu'ils y viennent les
catholiques les juifs
elle est n'est pas tout y est c'est tout
le programme du pq l'action vous savez
ça n'a pas changé il ya pourtant un mot
qu'on emploie maintenant dans le nouveau
clan et c'est le mot à rien ah voilà il
fallait qu'ils y viennent y sont déjà
ils veulent seulement dans le clan des
aryens c'est à dire de pure souche à
rien c'est le système de gobineau c'est
un mot aussi qui a été repris en europe
un peu plus tard et je n'ai pas besoin
de vous dire par qui
mais maintenant que clark et madame
tyler sont là qu'on s'est ni relais
réunion que maintenant l'on parle fort
que l'on parle avec violence et bien les
gens viennent de plus en plus et ben
tant ils sont cinquante mille et
puissant 1000 et 1300 milles en 1924
ils seront trois millions trois millions
imaginez-vous 3 millions d'américains
sous la cagoule et ces gens là on leur
en donne pour leur argent alors au mois
de mars 1921 deux noirs sont mutilés
sont émasculé parce qu'ils ont fréquenté
des femmes blanches et puis en 1922 il y
à 500 opérations goudron et plumes c'est
à dire que les noirs ou les blancs amis
des noirs sont plongés dans du goudron
et ensuite on les zones de plumes c'est
pour faire peur et puis il y à bien pire
il y a par exemple dans un petit village
le patron du clan qui est le docteur
mccoy n'est qu'ils ne se sent pas assez
d'autorité auprès d'eux
ses amis et alors il va dans un champ il
tire lui même il décharge son revolver
sur sa voiture ils reviennent montre les
trous et dire regardez les amis des
noirs les démocrates parce que
maintenant les démocrates se sont les
autres c'est comme ça en amérique
les démocrates vont attaquer alors le
clan immédiatement fait une enquête t on
et on pense que ce sont deux jeunes gens
et ces deux jeunes gens on va les
chercher on va les chercher on le
conduit dans un bois on les interroge
est ce que c'est vous il répond non non
non je nous irons que ce n'est pas nous
alors on les laisse partir
et puis il y a les jours suivants 1
dimanche un grand pique nique
vous savez que c'est la mode aux états
unis vous avez vu ça au cinéma les dames
sortent leurs grandes robes les grandes
chapeau les grande capeline on s'en va
on emmène des paniers ces charmants et
alors il ya une file de voitures qui
vont pique nique et puis tout à coup on
barre la route des hommes masqués et ont
fait descendre les deux jeunes gens
on les reverra pelé
on a fait descendre avec eux le père
d'un des deux jeunes gens
et puis on a battu ce père férocement
dans une clairière
et puis comme ce vieillard cet homme de
70 ans hurlait le fils qui étaient
attachés qu'ils avaient les yeux bandés
s'est débattu pour aller au secours de
son père et le bandeau est tombé et la
vue tout à coup devant lui à des clans
sman démasqué l'a reconnu a dit je te
reconnais c'est wayne va pas plus loin
parce que l'autre qui est une brute qui
est une brute herculéenne s'avancer lui
brise le bas du visage on sait plus s'il
a une mâchoire il ne peut plus que
parler dans un gargouillis informe et on
lâche le père fouetter et les deux
jeunes gens sont jetés sur le sol
déchirée par le fouet et ensuite on
amène un tracteur lentement sûrement qui
s'avance et qui les écrase alors ça ça
fait plaisir vous comprenez quand on est
membre des plus klux klan et qu'on se
dit au moins nous servons à quelque
chose nous on joue un rôle dans l'état
et en 1925 au mois d'août il y aura
quelque chose d'inouï quelque chose de
fantastique à washington une parade
mance quelque chose comme on n'a jamais
vu quarante mille membres du ku klux
klan qui vont partir de toutes les
provinces du sud qui prendront le train
qui prendront des voitures et qui
s'avanceront qui s'avanceront pour la
parade
et les américains découvriront après
cette longue marche tout à coup dans les
rues de leur capitale des files défi
l'immense de gens qui s'étaient arrêtés
d'abord lé voilà regarder les avances la
croix dans les rues regarder cette masse
est masse impressionnant et ça c'est le
cucs clan ce sont des gens qui veulent
la mort des noirs qui valent l'éviction
des catholiques la mort des juifs c'est
le ku klux klan c'est l'apogée 3
millions de morts un million de dollars
en caisse parce que toujours l'aspect
commercial et on les les gens du clan
paye 10 min 10 dollars par an lors il y
en a 5 pour le fonctionnement du plan
mais deux ennemis pour monsieur clark
madame tyler et et deux pour simmons et
que jose curieux cet apogée et en même
temps le début de la chute
parce que cet apogée c'est une prise de
conscience et tous les journaux en
parlent doucement fin ou allons-nous
c'est ce que nous sommes toujours là la
grande démocratie américaine
qu'est ce que c'est que ces gens n'ont
s'est laissé faire un barrage nous
voulons un barrage il ya des gens qui
réclament ce barrage et il ya des
membres du clan qui ont peur ils
doublement est l'histoire de
l'assassinât des deux jeunes gens vous
pensez bien qu'on voit la publie alors
il ya beaucoup de démission énormément
de démission et en 28 ils ne seront plus
que quelques centaines de milliers oui
depuis 3 millions quelques centaines de
milliers et puis et puis en 1939
simmons entre-temps a cédé sa place à un
homme et evans c'est evans à gouverner
le clan comme sort si impériaux les
pieds 27 de la place en 1939 a nommé
corps et scott lequel va conduire le
clan vers sa destinée à travers la
seconde guerre mondiale en 1939 le clan
il y a un grand détachement du clan qui
rencontre un grand attachement du bund
vous savez le bund mais il y avait
beaucoup en amérique d'allemandes oui
des gens d'origine allemande et l'autre
ces gens-là défilé en tenues nazis et où
il la chemise brune les bottes le
brassard à croix gammée le salut et ça
défile et bien imaginer dans un grand
champ
le ku klux sont à côté le bund de
l'autre et tout le monde camarade
camarade quand l'amérique que rentrer en
guerre ça devient un peu parce que
difficile alors le clan fait machine
arrière et en 1944 ça se trouve bien le
fisc réclame 6 185 mille dollars
d'impôts non payés à cory scott et
lequel dissous le clan on n'en parle
plus 44 est-ce que c'est donc fini banon
car en 46 ça repart c'est un certain
green maintenant qui ressuscite le clan
et pendant ces années 46 50 55 60 le
clan et là le clan est là bien sûr peu
nombreux il n'y a guère plus qu'une
cinquantaine de milliers de membres du
clan mais pendant ces années terribles
qui sont les années où il y des
américains veulent effacer cette honte
qui est la ségrégation raciale veulent
que les petits enfants noirs aillent à
l'école avec le blanc veulent que ce
soit fini de cette barrière entre les
deux races à bienne ya des gens qui sont
là toujours pour dire non et c'est le
clan qui dit non non non éternellement
non ce plan qui refuse et il y a des
morts beaucoup de morts il y a six morts
en milieu de 1956 et 1963 il ya six
noire il y a 6 noir assassiné il ya 29
blanc et noir tués au cours
d'affrontement ratio est le et le clan
est toujours là et quand vous avez vu
ces images dans ses enfants vont vers
les écoles et qu'il y à des blancs qui
sont là pour hurler ses enfants noirs
c'est en prendre à des enfants il ya des
blancs qui sont là pour hurler à mort et
bien c'est blanc ce sont des membres du
clan bien souvent alors il s'est passé
quelque chose qui ne pouvait pas prévoir
ces braves gens c'est que c'est noir il
s'était appliqué tellement a terrorisé
pendant tant d'années bien seynois a
beau jour ont relevé la tête et oui
toujours la même chose violence violence
et oui c'est devenu le black power le
pouvoir noir et des noirs qui disent
nous maintenant c'est fini on ne réclame
plus l'égalité c'est tout à fait autre
chose
on veut la révolution elle est blond les
chassera des états où nous
zadran ça va beaucoup plus loin et le
clan qui hélas fait maintenant non plus
figure d'assaillants mais figurent deux
groupes qui se défend alors oui il est
en perte de vitesse ce clan et c'est
tant mieux
mais réfléchissons il était en perte de
vitesse il a disparu en 1869
et puis il est né nouveau en 1915 il
était en perte de vitesse et il a
disparu en 1944 mais il est né nouveau
1946 car il semble que ce clan
correspondent à ses aspirations qui sont
hélas dans le coeur de tous les hommes
cette aspiration qui veut que parce que
quelqu'un n'a pas exactement la même
couleur de peau pas la même religion pas
la même philosophie on dit c'est
l'ennemi c'est l'autre c'est l'autre
cette aspiration qui fait que alors
qu'on serait là si on était seul et bien
si on est à plusieurs si on est en
groupe on est capable de tout et ça
c'est un double piège qui nous dit que
le clan ne fera pas de nouveau retombé
l'amérique dans ce piège et soyons
francs est ce que vous croyez qu'il n'y
a que les américains qui sont capables
dé tomber dans ce piège
[Musique]